madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
bourgogne en direct pour ce nouveau
numéro de la voie est libre une
délégation de l'association des maires
ruraux à manifester mardi devant le
sénat au moment où manuel valls faisait
son discours sur la réforme territoriale
ces élus ont voulu rappeler au premier
ministre que la france ce n'est pas
seulement lui redonne mais qu'elle est
aussi rural occasion pour nous
aujourd'hui de nous poser la question de
l'avenir des communes petites ou
moyennes et de l'évolution des
intercommunalités pour cela quatre élus
sont réunis sur ce plateau bruno
bethenod bonjour vous êtes né à
d'arceaux et président des maires ruraux
de côte-d'or pire coillot bonjour oui
mais redevient président de la
communauté de communes de l'ernée et
vous êtes également conseiller général
de la côte d'or anthony vadot bonjour
aux autres maires de branches président
de la communauté de communes coeur de
brasc et toute nouvelle qui datent de
cette année et série boulot bonjour
maire de villeneuve sur yonne président
d'une nouvelle communauté de communes
aussi cette ville me vient et conseiller
général de l'yonne n'oubliez pas comme
d'habitude vous pouvez vous aussi réagir
et poser vos questions à nos invités sur
internet à france 3 points bourgogne.fr
ou bien sur notre page facebook et sur
twitter #irl bourgogne ou ap f 3
bourgogne
vous avez participé à cette fameuse
manifestation devant le sénat mardi
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez tenu à
vous rendre à ce rendez vous pour passer
quelques messages
le message qu'on a voulu faire passer au
premier ministre lorsqu'il présentait un
des pans de réforme territoriale devant
le sénat c'était de lui rappeler que la
france était varié et diverses à travers
ce territoire à travers sa population où
ces populations et
qu'elle reflétait aussi départements les
régions et
parce qu
il le sait peut-être comme ça mais après
dans le quotidien dans la gestion du
quotidien se dire le politique c'est
celui qui doit constater appréhender
trouver des solutions
et tout ça dans un intérêt général
partagé
et on a envie un cours très rapidement
dans la gestion du quotidien
pour répondre à votre question je pense
qu'ils sont de temps à autre pourquoi
être méchant pour dire tout le temps
bien éloignée de la gestion du quotidien
il ya une question que méchante mais on
vous dit on alors à paris les maires
sont allés défendre leur chapelle leur
petit pouvoir sans tenir compte de
l'intérêt général pourquoi les citoyens
nous avons ce reptile est seul à
participer à l'effort national
vous mettez en avant ont démonté à paris
non pas pour défendre notre chapelle
quoique à 8 notre chapelle ce sont deux
concitoyens se sont au territoire ce
sont eux qu'on défend ce qu'on a voulu
démontrer c'est que l'organisation qui
mise en place de leur jeu elle a
certainement au fil des temps besoin
d'être revu
parce que l'évolution étant la modernité
les moyens de communication moyenne
transports sont plus les mêmes la
technologie est à est passée par là faut
faut se souvenir que nos communes nos
intercommunalités elle vit depuis plus
de 200 ans et communes c'est 1903 1906
ses 1800 3100 simple et les attire comme
via les premiers syndicats s'étaient
1865 donc c'est pas nouveau non on sait
travailler ensemble et puis sur la
gestion financière on en reparlera un
petit peu plus tard je pense que
beaucoup de choses sont dites sans
connaître vraiment d'arrietty chose
c'est le boulot le premier ministre a
dit kan meme peut il aller prendre en
compte les spécificités locales est-ce
que ça c'est quelque chose qui vous a
rassuré les uns et les autres c'est
important en effet que le premier
ministre prenne compte de la diversité
de nos territoires ici même les quatre
représentants nous avons des territoires
très différent peut-être avec des
orientations
territoriales qui ne vont pas tous dans
le même sens nous avons aussi nos points
de vue différents c'est normal que le
premier ministre à entendre ce que vont
dire les églises les associations d'élus
après entre les paroles et les faits
nous serons là aussi pour regarder ce
qui sera véritablement mis en oeuvre on
a aussi l'habitude d'entendre à gauche à
droite ou au centre de grandes
déclarations les élus locaux que nous
sommes sur le terrain engagé au
quotidien parfois nous voyons aussi
quelques nuances avec les discours par
rapport à ce que disait mon collègue et
par rapport surtout à la question de
votre internaute l'effort exceptionnel
des collectivités locales est là
également dans le projet de loi de
finances sur les trois ans à venir plus
de 11 milliards d'euros vont être
consacrés par les collectivités locales
au déficit de l'état est un peu plus de
3 millions 7,2 euros dès 2015 donc on
peut pas dire que les collectivités
locales n'ont pas conscience de l'effort
qui est leur est également demandé comme
nous contribuables transport à brétigny
la doc l'envolée reçu ce message du
premier ministre ça vous a assuré
forcément dans le discours il ya
toujours des ouvertures et on laisse
discussion lorsqu'on parle du seuil
minimum pour les communautés de communes
on voit peut-être qu'il y aurait un
pouvoir de mobilisation pour le près
formé des commissions départementales
mais par rapport aux dotations je
reprends ce qui était dit pour nous
c'est une vraie crainte de voir
certaines communes qui sont totalement
asphyxiée qui n'auront plus de capacité
de d'auto financer des investissements
enlevez 30% dotation c'est ce qu'annoncé
sur les trois ans qui viennent c'est
vraiment là en lever toute capacité une
commune de continuer à se développer de
faire travailler aussi ces entreprises
l'hôtel parce que si on se regroupe de
plus en plus les entreprises du bâtiment
des travaux publics voilà donc plus
forcément répondre à des marchés il y en
aura certainement moins en moins sur le
couple
tous les moyens que l'on pouvait avoir
on va y revenir les spécificités locales
finalement c'est compliqué de définir ce
que c'est une spécificité nom qui
employait
d'ailleurs dans chacune de vos chacune
de vos intercommunalités très différents
je pense notamment à la vôtre
tout à fait si vous permet d'avoir 2 me
par rapport à la question de
l'internaute je trouve qu'elle a raison
de dire qu'effectivement on ne peut pas
se limiter cette question-là l'effort
national je crois qu'il faut être
conscient soit on nous dit que la dette
c'est comme au monopoly c'est à dire que
c'est fictif rien encore effectivement
peut continuer soit une date réelle ce
qui me semble être le cas il faudra bien
on trouve des formules donc là dessus
des normales que tout le monde fasse son
autocritique entre guillemets et je
pense on y reviendra peut-être tout à
l'heure sur les moyens financiers des
collectivités qui a matière à discussion
sur le fond effectivement vous avez
raison moi je suis dans une
intercommunalité
je représente pour le moment une
intercommunalité de 2400 habitants 14
toutes petites communes sous l influence
docu de métropole donc des difficultés
économiques énormes et c'est vrai que si
je compare à mes trois indices y en ait
une situation complètement différente
la vraie question est posée derrière
tout ça et on y reviendra sans doute sur
la taille des intercommunalités sais
quel territoire aux voeux demain et si
on continue la la voix qui est orientée
depuis quelques années de plus on va
dire la réforme de 2010 su revenir là
dessus je mettrai les deux gouvernements
dans le même sac l'alouette 2010
l'actuel sûr qu'on a l'impression qu'une
espèce de course à l'échalote de celui
qui va donner le plus gros chiffre pour
la paix le minimum d'intercommunalité
pas si c'est un concours lépine aux
autres c'est quand même un peu différent
si au bout du compte on va vers cette
situation la 132 précautions vous aurez
dans vingt ans plus que les grandes
agglomérations point la ligne voire même
les très grandes agglomérations et ça
c'est quand même une vraie question
qu'il faut se poser parce que derrière
tout ça il ya des enjeux sociaux
considérables elles sans aller jusqu'aux
difficultés de la grande agglomération
parisienne
appartement comme la seine-saint-denis
on sait chacun que dès qu'on concentre
les gens la vie est extrêmement cher ça
pose des difficultés sociales avec des
gens qui ont parfois perdu des points de
repère qui ont des difficultés à se
retrouver avec des fromages galopant
avec des pertes de l'identité et puis
derrière tout ça dépend des mots chiffre
qu'il faut il évoquer le premier co
logique et de cadre de vie quand on
parle de l'énergie de ces choses là donc
tout ça je raconte bête en jeu on a
quand même rappelé que la réforme
territoriale elle a lieu en plusieurs
rapts ont fait 1 il ya déjà les
métropoles qui ont été créés cette année
en ce moment c'est le redécoupage des
régions donc le sénat a voté pour quinze
régions l'assemblée nationale avait voté
pour 13
qui donnera son dernier mot et qui en
fin d'année sera discuté la nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
république on appelle une autre je crois
qu'ils devraient donc clarifier les
compétences de chacun enfin j'allais
dire non c'est un petit peu ce que vous
attendez tous la
problématique c'est bien sa douche
numéro on a l'impression qu'on a mis un
peu la charrue avant les boeufs
parce que on parle de territoire de
découpage avant de savoir ce que l'on va
faire de l'or alors je sais bien que le
premier ministre a dit on fait ça en
parallèle il a dit ça l'autre jour au
sénat on est en train de faire sans
problème mais il avait quand même mieux
valu se poser la question
technique
des compétences des moyens qui fait quoi
comment avec quoi et pour revenir un peu
sur les dotations budgétaires
et sur la taille des communautés de
communes
je vais faire un point c'est que ce qui
est
la france c'est la france s'est rebellée
en 1972 contre marc cela les lois
martiales on est aujourd'hui en train de
revenir un petit peu avec dans le cadre
un peu de cette
de cette image de ce type de cette
prérogative de l'état par un terme il ya
des pouvoirs exorbitants qui sont donnés
ou qui vont être données aux préfets
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus les élus qui
vont décider ils vont décider à la
virgule c'est le préfet qui va dire bah
ceci cela est ans et quand on devra
contrecarrer eh bien je crois qu'on a
une majorité des deux tiers de ceux ci
des cela est donc
difficile c'est pas une décentralisation
on est en train de parler de refaire
aujourd'hui une recentralisation par les
pouvoirs qu'on donne au préfet et puis
on compte par exemple on dit alors en
france et ça c'est symptomatique se tape
très haut jeudi les communautés de
communes vingt mille habitants
pourquoi même il le monde pourra vite
surtout un an après cinq milles 1
nous sommes des fantassins nous marchons
sûrement mais lentement et l'on veut
nous faire courir sa propre marché je ne
sais le temps de digérer et puis
pourquoi un nombre pourquoi donc
laissons les élus locaux décider entre
eux de ce qui convient de leur
territoire la sanction seul élections
municipales enfants et on t'a pro et
puis après on dit ah on va mettre des
critères on va mettre un peu de
souplesse non on enlève le fait de dire
sevamy ou c est qu on laisse les élus
aménagé et choisir lors
leur territoire en fonction de leur
difficulté
finalement le probable décision qui sont
eux certains élus locaux
j'irai même je vais compléter ce qu'a
dit bruno bendo tout à l'heure moi j'ai
un peu le sentiment ça va paraître un
peu plus tarder tant pis depuis 2007
vous allez comprendre le message à
puisqu'il ya deux septennats neri qui
finit un autre qui comme un canard
quinquennat excusez moi kenneth fusée
mois
l'atavisme j'ai un peu l'impression que
on y lit après la république une fois
qu'il est élu il s'estime quasiment
investi d'un pouvoir personnel unique et
au demeurant ils oublient très
rapidement les promesses ou son
programme on amène sur la table
d'étrangers de loi et le parlement se
doit de se mettre le doigt sur la
couture du pantalon et de dire amen à ce
qui est proposé aux discussions oui mais
écoutez je veux pas rappelé les
événements récents ou ce qui s'était
passé dans ce canal pour faire le
pendant vous avez vu que les
parlementaires qui prennent des libertés
de d'action que je trouve louable parce
que chaque élu doit avoir sa propre
analyse on l'est on leur fait quelques
difficultés veut pas dire qu'on leur
fait comme faisait l'église avec
monseigneur gaillot qu'on les envoie
dans un diocèse disparu mais c'est
presque ça et qu'elle peut pas il ya
quand même un problème de démocratie
effectivement on a le sentiment
aujourd'hui
la façon dont c'est fait après avoir
décentralisée en deux étapes il ya 82 il
ya une 2004 me semble-t-il aujourd'hui
on veut reprendre je veux rappeler un
événement qui montre quand même que si
on reste unis ce important dans le
département de la côte d'or et bonhomme
et ne faisait partie me semble-t-il avec
moi à la cdci on avait décidé d'avoir
une position unique et que chaque élus
qui siègent des représentants
d'associations des maires de côte-d'or
s'était engagé par écrit avant d'y
siéger à ne pas prendre de décisions qui
est qu'ils rencontrent la vie des
territoires concernés ce qui fait qu'au
bout du compte on a obtenu mais je
trouve que c'est une bonne chose est la
préfète de l'époque s'y étaient rangés
peut-être par choix peut-être obligation
je ne sais pas mais peu importe à faire
qu'on n'oblige à aucune fusion no
souhaité quelque part ça me paraissait
une bonne chose donc quelque part même
si on a le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui dans
commettez qu'il est la loi qu'on
voudrait un petit peu revenir
au passage aux forces quoi il ya quand
même des ouvertures qui permettront je
l'espère aux élus et comme vous l'avez
dit des parlementaires sans débat nous
coûte aussi espérer qu'ils vont avoir un
peu de
liberté de parole on va y revenir dans
un instant sur les fusions éventuelles
des communes parce qu'on sent bien que
l'état voudrait que que ça y est un
petit peu plus vite la taille des
intercommunalités d'abord par exemple
car vous vous une nouvelle communauté de
communes qui fait 12 6 ans après treize
13 mille habitants nous allons être
obligés de revoir votre copie a priori
très prochainement c'est ça qui est
difficile c'est qu'on tricote détricote
parfois certaines qualités de communes
de mon voisin d'en face est à peu près
identique à la mienne mais du temps pour
se mettre en place pour faire naître un
consensus parfois même un compromis
assure sur les compétences qu'on va
fédérer ensemble et le seuil vient un
peu balayer une fois qu'on a mis en
place les choses que la qualité de
commune et est en route donc on se
retrouve face à cette épée de damoclès
au-dessus de nous donc c'est vrai que
c'est difficile pour les élus de
travailler sur les seuils bien sûr qu'il
faut des seuils à un moment ou un autre
ce qui compte à mon avis avant tout
c'est quand même la cohérence
territoriale c'est le bassin de vie
c'est les projets économiques y sont
portées sur un territoire c'est la carte
scolaire c'est la présence des voies de
communication
c'est la présence d'un tissu industriel
c'est les habitudes tout simplement
parce que je dis souvent les populations
font l'intercommunalité avant nous mêmes
avant les élus avant et décret avant les
règlements les habitants ont l'habitude
de se déplacer au collège ou lycée et en
vivres vêtements donc il faut des
bassins de vie mais ce seuil est parfois
à relativiser parce que emmener un seuil
de 20 milles au risque de détricoter
quelque chose qui va marcher ça peut
être contre-productif
le seuil il est la même chose sur les
régions on n'arrête pas de nous dire
qu'on a des régions en france qui sont
pas assez fortes mais si on regarde sur
les 21 pat est une région continentale
en gros on est à 2 9 millions de
buts en six matches et noir à côté de
chez nous nos voisins italiens nos
voisins espagnols nous sommes sur les
mêmes chiffres et même si on va un peu
plus loin sur les états fédéraux
américains la comparaison est souvent la
même donc ce qui compte avant tout c'est
la cohérence territoriale c'est
l'aménagement je dirais du territoire
j'ai peur que ces critères d'aménagement
du territoire
passe parfois à la trappe par rapport
aux réalités de terrain anthony la
nouvelle commune de comines vous êtes
bien dans le rang 21 21 ans habitant à
priori
votre communauté de communes il
s'appelle coeur de bras
franchement la bresse ça une certaine
identité c'est connu depuis l'extérieur
assure tous les temps pourquoi ne
préservent avoir du très grand
finalement est pas rare à lomé toute la
manche parce qu'il ya d'autres
communautés qui ont deux communes après
tout c'est vous qui ont aussi le nombre
à sa compliqué pour les jambes non lors
de la précédente mandature dont le seuil
des 5000 habitants il y avait la
question aussi des communes qu'il était
encore isolées voilà qui était hors
communauté de communes ce travail était
à peu près fait plus ou moins bien fait
mais je nous
ai effectivement les élus en côte d'or
mais c'était le théoricien saône et
loire ont été à peu près écouter et s'il
part de consentement la part des
communes ou communautés de communes il
n'y a pas de passage en force et avait
déjà des propositions pour faire une
brèche une commune de comines de
brésiliens plus large après on est resté
voilà on est passé de 2,9 son territoire
de besoin de neuf communautés de
communes à 6 effectivement au coeur de
bresse maintenant à un peu plus de 20000
habitants donc on est on revient avec ce
seuil
maintenant mais bon si dans trois ans
aux mains sales pourquoi pas qu'une
prochainement des monts à tour
législature à 25 35 ans mais pourquoi
pas parce que 50000 je pense voilà ce
sera fait
on n'y arrivera pas et autour de nous
beaucoup de territoires ruraux ont des
communautés de communes entre
5,10 1012 mig 15 mille habitants et même
en se mettant ensemble n'aille pas au
seuil de 20 mille dons on raconte que
vous analyserez les révolutions se
prononcer d'une révolution de remettre
tous les deux ans ou trois ans pendant
ce temps là on fait rien on bloque le
transfert de nouvelles compétences on
n'a pas le temps de travailler ça pollue
tout le débat de savoir si on va
fusionner ou non le périmètre exact ça j
aime beaucoup de choses et donc je pense
qu'on va arrêter ceci dans les
départements où cela n'est peut-être pas
encore été fait peut-être qu'il faut
encore améliorer
la carte des intercommunalités
mais chez nous on entend plutôt une
pause là dessus pour ne laisser
travailler un petit peu et nous laisser
aussi le faire en bonne intelligence
on a des syndicats mixtes au dessus de
nous
qui regroupe pour d'aménagement du
territoire qui ont déjà six communautés
de communes
laissez nous le temps peut-être de
transférer des compétences et syndicat
mixte peut-être qu'un jour on les
reconnaîtra comme communauté de communes
mais laissez nous le temps et faisant
d'une confiance car trio alors
communauté de communes de 2400 radicaux
c'est la taille de la côte de bronze
d'une collecte accrue viable alors là
dessus je vous aime merci vous me
permettez quelques minutes moi je pense
là dessus ça rejoint ce qu'ont dit les
collègues mais en plus d' plus en détail
il faut absolument que la communauté de
communes elles correspondent à un
territoire équilibré la territoire
équilibré ça n'a pas la même
signification souvent qu'on est sous
l'affluence de l'agglomération
dijonnaise veut titiller un peu mon
collègue est venu on se connaît depuis
longtemps ou bien qu'on est dans
l'agglomération de ville deux bouts de
loin ou qu'on est à liernais dans
l'agglomération de rien du tout
dernièrement
j'ai pas vraiment une agglomération
henry et ça donc ce que ce que je
regrette un peu aussi dans ce texte et
depuis le début depuis l'album 2010
c'est que la taille il ya plusieurs
façon de l'exprimer la population son
étude mais la surface en est une autre
par exemple on aurait pu aussi évoqué ça
alors je sais nous on a échappé la
fusion parce qu'il y avait de la loi n
2010 l'article 35 alinéa je sais plus
combien qui disait que ce seuil ne
s'appliquait pas au territoire avec des
communes en zone de montagne
heureusement d'ailleurs l'association
des élus de la montagne bhl est dans ce
sens là mais je vais vous donner un
autre exemple
il faut pas pendant groupe il ne faut
pas prendre en compte que la sphère de
la taille il ya aussi une question
d'intégration c'est à dire que s'il
suffit pas de faire une communauté de
communes si elle a très peu de
compétences ça sert à quoi d'autre qu'à
faire des fentes fonctionnement
supplémentaire et ça rejoint d'ailleurs
de la question que posait composent l
internaute nous nos petits territoires
certes à 2400 habitants mais depuis sa
création de 1000 points on a pris la
compétence affaires scolaires en
totalité on y reviendra tout à l'heure
sur les investissements fonctionnement
père y parlera pendant deux ans face aux
anglais on appelait la voirie communale
en totalité et on appelait le
développement économique en totalité
vous allez me dire dans votre territoire
c'est peut-être modeste sauf que si on
n'avait pas pris cette compétence et
qu'on n'ait pas racheté et rénové louis
cinq commerces de proximité aujourd'hui
c'est tous fermés alors vous répondez
peut-être à la question de charge est
qu'il disait justement voilà réflexion
qui disait la communauté de communes
n'arrête pas d'augmenter les impôts je
sais pas où elle habite
je ne vois pas bien l'intérêt pour moi
vous qui êtes dans la religion c'est
encore un autre à notre
commune lumière des lois s'est maintenue
commune de 1500 habitants après tout on
est on est trop petit nom
selon les critères selon certains
critères
on n'est pas dans le scot
on n'est pas dans le schéma
conventionnel on n'est pas dans le grand
dijon et à la limite on est limitrophe
de la ville
on a une influence de la bile ce qui ce
qui nous permet de nous le dire est la
deuxième la troisième couronne d'avoir
un dynamisme
plus important que mon collègue pierre
sur cette mythique commune qui fait de
l'attraction un haut niveau de
l'urbanisme au niveau même souhaite mais
on s'aperçoit aussi on a eu certaines
difficultés
le grand dijon
une grande partie de sa fiscalité était
basée sur la taxe professionnelle
sur les entreprises
et lorsque nous
communes proches ne voulions créer une
zone économique
nous étions très surveillée pour pas
dire autre chose très surveillé je me
suis battu pour faire pour installer en
6,7 en tête en entreprise sur l'autre
sur notre commune comme la commande
commune
alors les compétences
je comprends très bien que dans un
territoire comme pierre on essaye parce
que il faut regrouper mais sa part d'un
constat et d'une volonté locale
si ces choses là elles sont pas
intimement partagée par les élus et
leurs populations on a beau les imposer
du dessus on n'arrivera à rien on se
rassure du statu quo donc ce que je dis
et je redis ne parlons pas de seuil
minimal
laissons les élus en fonction de grandes
critiques l'état qui donne des
directives
et ensuite on s'organise pour essayer
d'atteindre six directives mais n'impose
rien aux élus alors là je vais tenter de
vous contredire pour alimenter le débat
je vous donne la parole à pierre caillot
venons injustement ou aux communes
elles-mêmes parce qu'on a notamment
raymond qui nous dit pourquoi ne pas les
supprimer tout simplement urbaines ou
rurales et favoriser l'explosion plus
grande donc les intercommunalités
on en parle on en parle réponse d'ici
deux cent cinquante ans demande t-il
mais un vous dit qu'on ne doit pas
imposer mais finalement l'allemagne elle
l'a fait de façon assez autoritaire
à
discute avec les allemands puis
il ya 15000 commune en espagne et en
italie là que quelques centaines au
royaume uni est-ce que c'est pas une
question
si vous permettez je reviens tout petit
peu d'avis sur la question de
l'internaute un matelot sur l'histoire
des coûts moi je souhaite placer soit
transparent je voudrais préciser que ma
petite communauté de communes elle
fonctionne avec une seule employée
administrative 26 heures par semaine et
j'aimerais bien que l'on fasse puisque
l'objectif il est quand même affiche au
départ et il est louable dudit vie du et
la dépense j'aimerais bien qu'on ait
l'honnêteté le courage de dire est ce
qu'on augmentant la taille en population
insiste sur le mot taillan population
parce qu'il entendait y est ce qu'on va
forcément baisser les coûts sont un
exemple très simple si on fait de très
grandes communautés c'est pas le cadre b
de kayes parce qu'ils ont une grande
population mais sur un territoire réduit
regardez ce qui s'est passé dans ce
fatras c'est pas une critique c'est un
constat c'est tout on a fait une grande
communauté de communes dont ils ont des
21 mille habitants sauf que ça fait
territoire tellement vaste qu'on ne peut
pas gérer la vie quotidienne sur un
territoire où il ya des habitants qui
sont à 60 km du chef-lieu ou presque ça
veut dire qu'on a conservé à côté de la
communauté de communes qui a sa
structure administrative des sivom pour
gérer la voirie en général d sivos de la
parfois deux par petit ancien canton
tout ça fait des coûts donc il faudrait
bien qu'on ait l'honnêteté
intellectuelle de dire comparant les
coûts et puis on va voir si
effectivement c'est en augmentant
détails qu'on revient je reviens à votre
question sur la lah à les voler
moi j'ai pas d'interdît je dis
simplement qu'il ya deux choses à
prendre en compte 1 il faut garder un
principe de proximité c'est-à-dire
question fait des communautés de
communes qui demain je le dis moi sans
état d'âme dans des territoires comme le
nôtre j'ai revolé essentielle de la vie
quotidienne parce que la taille des
petites communes fait qu'on ne peut pas
faire autrement il ne faut pas que deux
chefs-lieux soit distant de plus
toujours fixé 15 km si vous êtes à plus
de 15 km du lieu où se décident où se
gèrent votre vie quotidienne l'école le
collège la poste le médecin un
pharmacien enfin tout ce que vous allez
mettre derrière les commerces de
proximité
excusez moi quel serait l'avenir d'un
territoire qui serait plus éloigné que
ça donc quelque part moi je dis les
communes ça fait partie de notre
histoire il faut sans doute les garder
sur le plan de l'image il faut par
contre que le statut évolue que le
préfet de la côte-d'or envoie les mêmes
courriers au maire de viande 45
habitants 50 habitants et au maire de
dijon il ya peut-être un peu des
aménagements trouvés dans le
fonctionnement et une évolution
gardez vous qui êtes à la fois maire et
président
relativement rapidement parce qu'on va
faire comment pour le journal
les gens sont très attachés à leur
commune après il ya des dispositifs
comme les communes nouvelles qui
permettent à deux ou trois ou quatre
voilà de se mettre ensemble d'abord une
incitation financière pour ceci il faut
que ça soit consenti
sol la base du volontariat les choses se
font
parfois voilà s'empêche pas qui est un
débat au niveau préfectoral ou qu'il
rassemble outre la table il faut souvent
que les représentants de l'état le fasse
mais qu'on ne l'a pas des seuils pour
nous obliger pour dire voilà c'est après
une tête d'une commune sait combien ces
500 habitants ces cinq ans émile ses
1500 on n'y arrivera jamais sale boulot
pas d'autoritarisme
je pense qu'il faut il faut du bon sens
les élus comme les populations peuvent
participer à ce bon sens et cet intérêt
général
supprimer les communes qui nous attend
encore expliquer le bien fondé non plus
de cette disposition on nous parle
d'économie est ce que dans les autres
pays son combat il ya plus d'économies
avec moins de communes c'est pas si
évident que ça on rappelle c'est quand
même l'échelon de proximité et on a une
petite tendance à oublier qu'en zone
rurale c'est aussi le maintien du
service public au plus près des
habitants donc supprimer les communes
qui font participer à la vie des
villages on risque d'avoir un phénomène
encore pire de désertification rurale
je suis aussi favorable aux coopération
évidemment qu'il faut des directives
sinon on aurait encore des communes
isolées peut-être que l'intercommunalité
ne se serait pas mis en marche je trouve
on serait des villages comme je dis bien
des villages gaulois allez on en reparle
dans quelques nous allons continuer
cette discussion là on va sur une courte
pause pour prendre connaissance de
l'actualité à la mi-journée le flash
régional est présenté ce midi par examen
a tout de suite